We actually have some very exciting news that we just got in the mail.
So we've been working on a protein powder,
and we just got the first
full bag in the mail with the packaging,
everything, and I am like,
I'm having a moment. It's so exciting.
You know, anybody who's followed me for some time
knows that one of our favorite things to do
is to put maple syrup, little bit of cinnamon in a glass jar,
and then when we go milk the cow,
we just, like,
squirt the milk into it, and it makes, like, the most delicious
drink. That's the first flavor that's gonna go out
is our Maple cinnamon protein powder that's made with, um,
colostrum. Because that's another thing that I just love,
is that, like,
amazing colostrum. The first few days of lactation,
they just put a little lid or.
AMA ağzım Soyuyo.
Hmm.